321 vai só a sanção ser um ator
acreditamos no brasil estão iguais um
dos meus óculos falei de luan eu sei
fazer
assim o lado de sua obra que fala
mandarim que sejam muito bem vindos
camarão dele a mostrar vecchi pessoal o
tão esperado o vídeo vai contribuir
menos para a ciência para biologia
humana ou animal macho que é macho
animal vai contribuir para o
desenvolvimento deste planeta pois nós
vamos observar esperma de cavar o comics
com sexual pois tanto tempo a procura
aqui encontrei eu encontrar eu nunca
pensei que um cavaleiro participar do
meu vídeo pelo menos desta forma mas
exatamente só se tiverem o comer ou
foram em cima de coisas legendas este
não é pra vocês não só salve salve
depois nós vamos ver espero mais cavalos
mas vamos ver se em dois meses esperando
a noiva consolidado uma banana contra
muita coisa projetou hoje até reiner
jovem dinamismo e é isso o jogo vai ser
um gênio mas se vocês forem fortes e
conseguir ver este vídeo já fazem deste
o vosso negra li ke bota atingir os 3
mil likes neste vídeo para ver mais
coisas nojentas de fruta podre coisa
pode um pássaro morto eu inclusive já
tenha nenhum software em que mais dizer
coisas sem me light neste vídeo olha só
ela que tem uma mostra de espera mas
acabam não dá para ver muito bem é só um
pouquinho mesmo e eu nem sei se vai dar
muito certo nem por um microscópio bt 20
mil de punição eu acho que nós para
conseguirmos atender 1 espera mandar
embora mas tem que ter uma punição de 25
mil a 22 mil então vamos lá tentar
pessoal e não resultar eu acho que vamos
ver obrigado a comprar um microscópio
tipo daqueles mais profissionais só não
vou mostrar muito isso porque recebem
gráfico nerd e eu deixasse um cheiro
forte mas vamos lá só 321 vôos de
caixinha
o shopping já é forte mas renê que isso
é muito mau
vamos lá pessoal a outra coisa para eu
mostrar o meu bom eu comprei mas que
devido basicamente o que eu vou fazer é
bom por aqui um pouco do esperma e
depois fechar com outro vidro então week
vai espalhar ainda mais nós vamos
conviver melhor com microscópio eu acho
agora eu não sei se a espessura do vidro
é mais correta
é mas vamos tentar aguentar essa é a
parte difícil agora é do chamado espera
bateu no vidro
[Música]
eu nem vou pensar o que eu vou fazer eu
só vou fazer agora vamos deixar o outro
vidro ou o espanhol muito para isso ao
bater justamente aí terá que aprender
coisas não estão a correr nada bem na
nova york só eu que tenho de melhor isso
tudo combinado só vou tentar saber
definir mesmo fala que temos ao nosso
microscópio e bailar 321 vai
completamente por cima
ok não dá pra ver ainda muito bem e vou
tentar aproximar aqui olha só oque é um
vidro mas a primeira que já as linhas do
esperma na primeira disputa mente o
calma
já está virando qualquer coisa mas mesmo
assim não funciona só com podem estar
tudo branco isso nem foca assim tanto
olha aí um cavalo um cavalo que o
esperma do cavalo eu sei como funciona
mas por cima do gol mesmo só os cliques
é muito difícil porque nós temos que ter
a mesma base que se ficar a cápsula já
coloquei aqui o vídeo
funciona eu acho convites não funciona
ainda por cima tem os lusos uol
olha só não for eu estou me sertão
cobrinhas olha aí o mesmo movimento foi
muito rápido
o quinto andar muito rápido num cavalo
passar uma bolha gigante caída próxima
leva para cima mas há muita coisa que
mexe eu não sei se os projetos adiante
mas outra coisa é chique suas fãs
quiserem cultura que os microscópios de
pulso mpt tempo de 10 mil ton em um
comentário como infectar que compra
microscópio de 10 mil e subiu tiver
muito comentário eu vou comprar um
microscópio e vamos ver o esperma é
realmente como o leque muito amplo e até
mesmo para lá só vamos lá pessoal a
próxima coisa nojenta primeiro aqui
comigo na escala api ou néné a gente é
uma banda qualquer néné é uma banana
podre muito podre 321 vai agora dar um
zoom básico wall e olhem bem estranho
por ser terra ou areia qualquer coisa
assim está bem estranho
an a podridão está podre e vamos tentar
ver aqui pra cima ele é um louco mas não
só textura da banana é meu direito o meu
bem um louco
olha aí é muito nojento microscópio e
tem um belo de um tempo aí vai uma
textura muito louca e branca e ainda
possível de proteínas
a próxima coisa nojenta cheia muita
paixão
a pasta que vendeu a parte mais massinha
e depois ver com o pregão que faz mais
porque bola só 3 2 1
vai que um louco mas não sou eu tenho
muita textura
eu tenho muitos filamentos ali dentro o
que é isso que o uso normal e vamos
tentar dar um zoom de 12 mil agora olha
aí muito lá dentro dos filamentos
olha só a poderiam isso agendado
aprender muita coisa suja só tem pelo
aqui eu vou tentar encontrar aqui parte
mais suja esta questão que vai ter muita
coisa aqui dentro
olha aí terrestre de gordura meu eu nem
sei que isto é é muito nojento algo
muito nojento aí vai eleger mas não como
quem diga senhor é um gato e não só
vamos lá então vem a parte mais nojenta
que partido verde escura foi só meu tem
muita sujidade aqui tem um bocado de
carne tem cabelo tem que gordura não é
só a parte branca é toda a gordura o que
é isto aí queijo queijo que olha sou um
cinto ou em quantidade de gordura mel
que nojo
outra coisa bem nojento só vou contar
daqui a um dia do meu pé e vamos ver se
o microscópio você que nós já vimos
algumas foi a da mão e normalmente as
unhas dos pés tem bem mais de idade bem
mais coisas lá dentro e por isso eu vou
cortar a unha e vamos ver o que acontece
basta unir para lá
[Música]
a lei 3 2 1 e do pé microscópio um ato
fosse meu receio é só a minha unha rg
pelo bicho nem tudo estava aqui de um é
só pelo hotel morta bactérias lixo tem
muito lixo e eu consegui ver nada que
não há previsão de data aproveitamento
limpa tem qualquer coisa sou eu acho que
o meu cabelo e tem uma textura muito
estranha
tem muitas cores claro que tem pelo
menos tempo segundo o mundo várias
outras coisas mas nem sabemos que temos
vamos tentar ver outras coisas nojentas
que eu tenho aqui também com frasco com
o reino deles é bem nojento e vamos lá
pessoal 32 11 indonésios só vai nenhum
líquido estranho e aproximar aqui
a vontade tem que ir lá para fora vejam
só o reino pessoal tem que as bolhas do
reino que não tem tots3 mulheres têm uma
bolha gigante e não teve mais nada né eu
não quero mais isso e vamos falar agora
nós vamos ver sangue eu tenho aqui uma
picada de mosquitos na perna está a
deitar muito sangue e eu vou passar esse
povoado interna e vamos ver como é que o
sangue e no microscópio não vai aprender
e assim tanta coisa é porque eu acho que
é preciso mais mais potentes microscópio
mas vamos tentar
olha aí pessoal sem muito rap 3211 vai
aproximar e vou pra cima eu duvido que
prevê qualquer coisa que leve vamos
tentar né
ok tenha o máximo agora e não dá pra ver
nada está tudo completamente vermelho
tubarão estão superlotados médio no
álbum é já só está agora olha só é bem
brasileiro só você e eu vou ter mesmo
comprar um microscópio real mesmo que os
potentes
eu quero muito ver melhor o sangue
esperma microscópio mas só conseguiu
passar pois só bola tentar chegar aos
100 mil likes no filho e já sabem se
quiserem cumprir os 4 novo comenta e
embaixo e não só aí eu acho que já
estamos fazendo este vídeo como eu sei o
que vocês acharam mas foram os peruanos
gente está morrendo no gento o sangue
nojento como tem exatamente do meu lado
vão por ser mais vídeos podem ainda não
viram eu acho que não viram mas vai
juntar muito louco e pessoal quem vai
até a próxima